we have an icon in the wings okay is
this really happening because i heard
someone was going to be here and i can't
even wrap my little head around it we've
been asking her for a while
because we're such huge fans of hers for
everything she's done in her life
and also the really fun world she's
created on twitter that just has
everybody on the twitter feeder
and on her highly trafficked twitter
account
she is as we know the big bridger tin
fan and she has been demanding
the return of the duke please welcome
someone we have been waiting with
anticipation and having the pleasure and
the honor of speaking with
please welcome music icon six time
grammy award winner
and the queen of twitterverse now dion
warwick the legend
we know that you are our sister in
bridgerton hood right
uh and uh a topic near and dear dear to
your heart
is reggae john page uh gq says the
dashing duke
should be the next james bond
uh i'd watch that someone needs to take
over for daniel craig he's retiring from
bond after his fourth and final
uh double seven film no time to die and
um
reggae is in the mix do you think he'd
make a good one honey as far as i can
say he can do
anything he wants all
totally agree now there are other names
in the mix let's see there's a michael b
jordan who would be great too right
harry styles is in the mix
what do you think of harry styles now
well i feel like i love the other male
ideas but i'm still voting for reggae
jean paige
dionne what do you think yeah that's a
bit of had a heartbeat right there you
know what i'm saying
i do i've always been with james bond
represented that
sex symbol but still swab and
yeah yeah there was one other name too i
want to get your opinion on idris elba
absolutely
incredible yeah he's another heart drop
you know i saw him once outside of the
golden globes and he was like
he needed his car that's like my one
story he was like i need the car we got
to get in the car see that's already
that makes a good bond
he's got somewhere to go gotta get in
the car like crime dissolved
of course i wanted to like stop and chat
with him but i was like he really seems
like he needs to get somewhere so i'm
not
gonna annoy him right now but i was
freaking out that i was next to
interstellar but this was like
i don't know 12 years ago you were
rubbing elbas
yes i was i i had the pleasure of
meeting him at
the premiere of one of his films i can't
remember the name of the film in fact
and i met his daughter so i met his
fiancee at the time
uh oh i said charming admit true
i love him okay next story we are
talking the latest in wedding fashion
the new bridal trend popping up on the
internet is
the bridal bucket hat it's the bucket
hat
the 90s movie made famous but in wedding
white
instead i don't know why the 90s movies
made this famous i think fishermen made
this face
yeah it's a little like fish stick dion
i would love to get your take on this
um i don't know why any pride especially
bride
who wants to look like a fisherman
the bell is the mystery you know
that is the mysterious part of being a
bride when
nobody really sees they anticipate
that lifting of the available see that
beautiful face
i'm getting married soon do you think i
should wear a veil oh no
understood thank you all right write
that down for me okay
dion you've spread so much joy this year
over twitter
and now we're gonna get even more dionne
in a live stream
concert event is this right yes that's
right
mother's day may 9th it's going to be a
wonderful wonderful evening uh we did
one for easter
and that that went over exceptionally
well we had a lot of fun people
appreciated it and they missed
the music as i do so
mother's day may 9th google dion warwick
doug mandolin
and we'll all spend the afternoon and
evening together
i'll be there we cannot wait for that
thank you dion warwick for finally
joining us here on the show where there
is just nothing but love for you
thank you i certainly appreciate that
and you guys take good care of
yourselves please